this is the historic cambridge hotel in
upstate new york it's set in stunning
countryside a few hours drive from
manhattan
the hotel has 16 bedrooms and a large
restaurant and has had its doors open
for almost 150 years welcome to the
cambridge hotel
ex-military man and local lawyer john
imhoff persuaded his family to help him
buy the hotel in 2007.
i remember sitting in my hot tub smoking
a cigar drinking bourbon and life was
good and i wanted to take my wife
someplace nice for dinner so i said to
her why don't we buy the cambridge hotel
and then we'd have a place to go
he must have hit me at a weak moment
because i said
sure
hug
with zero hospitality experience between
them which one is 827 i don't i don't
know the numbers the hotel currently
falls shockingly short of guest
expectations it's dingy and there's hair
all in through here all over these
pillows be nice if we had a remote
control they're just gobs of hair we've
had remote control since when the 70s
i'm not sleeping here we're checking
it's bad
when i bought the hotel i didn't intend
to be a hands-on owner but i am always
at the hotel doing something one person
has to be in charge i got 84 emails 17
from john
john is a control freak how are we doing
on that chicken that's working hard we
can do better chef it's ready to murder
with this menu there's a lot of
restrictions to it our budget's really
tight the creativity's kind of gone out
the window
brett um all the room's clean yeah of
all the rooms coming in i am currently
the general manager x that's interesting
but john takes away my control i have no
control but general john's hands-on
approach isn't working
nobody wants to stay and the hotel is
losing thousands of dollars every month
john wants to put every penny that we
have into this hotel
and that is something i am no longer
willing to do
we are 750 000 in debt
but failure is not an option and i don't
intend to fail the hotel unless i can
fix things and fast john and tina will
lose their business and their home
if gordon ramsay can't fix us
who the hell else can
wow the real sense of grandeur
definitely some history here famous
hotel established 1885 home of piler
mode
i've been across america i did not
realize it came from here
good morning
good morning and welcome to the kingdom
headquarters
uh gordon and your first name my name is
brittany i'm the manager i have you in
room 117. that is 105 during the weekday
and 135 on the weekend okay i think
gordon's first impression of the hotel
is going to be
what the [ __ ] are these people doing the
cambridge hotel r.i.p seriously yes it's
died you mean no
rest in peace is the ghosts
that ha
live here
we are haunted oh come on there's a
little girl who supposedly haunts the
hotel
alice
alice
oh my good god she looks like something
out of the exorcist she was four years
old in 1913. when she died but i believe
in ghosts at the hotel
i absolutely believe in them i'm gonna
go up the stairs creaky as well
and oh god
uh are they the owners no i don't know
who they are those have been here this
place is littered with freaky pictures
what's upstairs there that is our third
floor why is that roped off because it
is not accessible to our guests
some of the coaster well that's where
people say they are
if he goes up on the third floor
he is going to freak out
this is your room
oh my god bloody hell
look at the wallpaper
what's the post up there what is that
just there so there's no handcuffs
no okay so so it's not a sex thing it is
not a problem it's a really weird thing
to have in the bed
welcome to the cambridge hotel thank you
christ almighty i am not going to forget
this day in a hurry
horrible linen
rough and nasty
holes
look at that
and the bed doesn't even fit the base
honestly i've seen better linen
inside hospitals horrible
my bedroom is dated and uncomfortable
how could anyone think this was good
enough for paying customers
bye-bye
can i meet the owners yes i'll be right
back with the owners
look how dead they are
[Music]
gordon
this is tina and john imhoff
nice to see you nice to meet you sir
john likewise good to see you both it's
quite amazing when you drive up and you
see this sort of statue of the building
yes sir isn't it beautiful it's stunning
until we get inside
hotel experience prior to this was what
very very little i mean i was no none
none
so year one what was the profit we lost
about three hundred and fifty thousand
dollars the first year year two two
hundred and fifty thousand 000 profit
loss loss so we're in for 600 000
within 24 months of business who's
funding this well um my mom and dad have
put in
several hundred thousand dollars
wow um our children our children your
children yes yes shea has put about
twenty five thousand dollars on credit
cards shea is your the oldest daughter
that's your oldest daughter right it's a
chef's um significant other okay and so
my youngest daughter uh just letting us
ten thousand dollars your youngest
daughter she's in college is your house
on the line next yes it is up for sale
and we would live here we would move on
to the third floor where'd you draw the
line say stop this is not working you're
standing there like proud [ __ ] very
confident very happy and like nothing's
gone wrong but
taking money from your daughter that
hasn't even started i would never ask
her on the path of her career i believed
that we would be able to turn it around
i know but john i'm sorry your parents
money your family's money your
daughter's money i i do have a positive
attitude there's a difference between
sounding positive and sounding
full of crap
he doesn't know me and he doesn't know
the situation i'm a military guy i'm not
gonna take chef ramsay's [ __ ]
i've just met the owners of the
struggling cambridge hotel and
discovered they've borrowed money from
their kids to stay open i i do have a
positive attitude there's a difference
between sounding positive and sounding
full of crap
unbelievable tina how do you manage i
don't know how i manage and i was very
close to running away several times
wow
seriously
unreal thank you
i've been frustrated for years with him
not listening to me when somebody
doesn't listen to you for a while you
just give up
what is it about john that's driven his
wife and potential guests away i need to
watch the general in action
what do you do with the hoover welcome
nice to see you sorry about the owner
walking through with a hoover are you
joining us for a sleepover or are you
joining us for dinner
excellent yeah
kimberg tell me i'll help you
john keeps himself constantly busy but
he's busy doing all the wrong things
his non-stop fussing and fidgeting is
killing the hotel's atmosphere
[Music]
the tables in the bar might be clean but
i've got an eerie feeling the food's
going to be filthy only one way to find
out
hello sir are you good my name's phillip
i'll be your server you want to
thank you
i'm a little nervous
so am i
um what would you recommend well the
soup du jour today is a uh vegetarian
lentil vegetarian lentil yup and what
was the super jewel yesterday it was
also the vegetarian oh so soup every two
days
uh actually it's longer than two days
um i'll go for the pork and beans
duck comfy yeah um piler mode okay okay
i think we're done okay thank you
thank you very much chef thank you
chef orders up okay thank you get them
going brother get them going i think
that gordon is gonna love the food chef
rich is great
we put out excellent food hey chef
[Music]
wow look at that this is the pork and
beans
holy mackerel
it's cold in the middle
both of you yeah just touch the meat
there please
touch that
ice cold i can see why we've got r.i.p
on the front of the [ __ ] reception
those are two medium rares right
scooters chuck them in the oven please
chef ice cold in the middle
tell them it's a sous-vide product we
cook it to order
it disappoints me a little bit that we
are
boiling bags putting stuff in the
microwave i wish we could actually
cook with fresher food
your duck con feet
and chef said the pork and beans was a
sous-vide product and it's cooked to
order
sous-vide oh we cooked in a bag yes
they're frozen frozen yes
and this plate that's frozen i think
that's a sous-vide product as well do we
have anything that is homemade are the
apple pies made here the apple pies are
made here okay can you hurt the desserts
please sure thank you
so far everything has been terrible
surely the hotel's signature dish is
going to be better
how's the apple pie
that we don't want to complain anymore
i'm sorry but this is the home of apple
pie alamos but if it's the home of that
plow motor should be really badass
stay away from me it looks like it was
vomit
i'm bringing it home from my dog
okay
wow
so this is it this is the that is the
paella mode
[ __ ] this plate is absolutely roasting
in the center has it been microwaved it
has
the apples are raw
if there's one thing i was expecting was
a decent apple pie and that is gross
i need to find out who's responsible for
the terrible food here
hello
if chef ramsay criticizes chef's food
where is the where is chef
i think rich will blow up because rich
does take things personally i don't know
where to start to be honest
what the [ __ ] is going on well tell me
what you didn't like can you be a little
bit more constructive shall we start
from the pork and beans stone [ __ ]
cold it's a sous vide probably so you
don't even cook that no sous vide no and
can you cook yes so why buy that in
um price
you buy a store-bought frozen piece of
pork
boiled in a bag and serve it to me stone
cold in the center you're not even
cooking
so you're just too lazy to do it that's
not true i am not wasted this menu can
be run now without you being here yes
that's the way i designed it this is why
you designed it
so you are lazy then i'm not lazy if
gordon calls me lazy one more time it
could cause a problem
i might be going back to brighton in a
body bag
i just tasted the food at the cambridge
hotel and it was awful i think it's
because the chef is lazy but he's
adamant he's not that menu stinks of
laziness i'm not lazy i'm here 80 90
hours a week yeah you can't call
yourself an executive chef come on
do you know it's still bored i did
why would you employ a chef that
two-thirds of the menu is store-bought
i i think gordon believes that i'm
incompetent in running a hotel but
what i'm doing is right your hotel
became famous for this apple pie right
and this is the dish that is trying to
stop your house
being put up for sale to keep this place
going but i'm just what i'm trying to
say is there are so many basics wrong i
could [ __ ] cry i could seriously i
could cry too and look at the apples
look the apples are raw not even baked
and i could scream when i see that
this this was invented here and there's
thousands of restaurants across the
globe that have copied what you
originated have you any idea how lucky
you are
and it resolves to that soggy
undercooked soaking wet
piss pie can i have a quick word with
you for two seconds please i'm
struggling to understand what's going on
here i need to hear a woman's
perspective john
is smart in what he does as a lawyer
he's awful here i can't
get it in his head but between the two
of them they're about to take your
[ __ ] house down
him and john go back and forth when i
give suggestions is pretty much you know
up
and then
it's pushed aside and then john is
making decisions
you're about to lose your house i know
and he says we are going until i haven't
got another penny to put in it he's
never run a business before no no and
he's never done anything in his life but
be a lawyer and a soldier
that is it he may have won lots of
battles but he's [ __ ] definitely
losing this war let me tell you
finally a stranger is seeing what i've
been seeing and i'm hoping that john is
going to take something from this and
either we're going to make it go
or we're going to shut it up
[Music]
i've seen about as much as i can stand
at this hotel the outdated rooms the
cheap linens and the pre-packaged food
how have things got this bad i've got to
get some answers
what's wrong with this place and who's
to blame problem is here is that
we have to ask
to do something
we're not allowed to make a decision
we're not going to make a general
manager executive chef we have to run
everything through john make sure
everything what we have to do john's a
lawyer so why do you have to ask someone
that doesn't know how to run a [ __ ]
bath let alone a hotel and he took over
more control that's when i put up my
hands okay you want to run it you run it
it's [ __ ] soulless
it's littered with [ __ ] antiques that
are broken
it's got horrendous pictures all over
the [ __ ] place disgusting rooms food
that comes out of a [ __ ] bag
i don't control any of that stuff
i'm not making decisions i told rich
that i thought we should cut our food
cost
have you got the respect
from the owners to do your job properly
yes or no
no
rick i have energy talk
i definitely do not make the decisions
that i think i should be able to though
she's telling you that and that's what
the problem is
it's not the [ __ ] ghost john
that's scaring
the regulars away it's you
a chef needs to be a [ __ ] chef and
the general manager needs to general
manage i'm not a micro manager
when we first started this place and the
ideas i had were all shot shot down
that's the kind of stuff now it's coming
out
you've handicapped the chef the general
manager's functional and you're calling
all the [ __ ] shots i'm not calling
the shot you're a lethal weapon well you
you may think that no i don't think that
i [ __ ] know that no just heard from
your wife your general manager your chef
then i'm controlling over control you're
like a little [ __ ] hitler around here
and if you don't stop doing what you're
doing
you'll lose your family
and the business
[Music]
i finally got to the truth at the
cambridge hotel you're like a little
[ __ ] hitler around here
the place is sinking because john the
owners meddling ways have made
everyone's jobs impossible
i'm not a micro manager they're not
puppets
they're your team and if you don't stop
doing what you're doing you'll lose your
family
and the business
working out
your honor
i'm going to bet
good night
this is all
stuff that i've been trying to get
across to john for 20 years
what's the matter
seriously yeah what's the matter with
you right now you have a headache again
i've had it
i have had it i was feeling squashed
and i don't have to feel that way
anymore i'm not gonna feel that way
anymore
bedtime
and i'm not looking forward to sleeping
in a haunted room i've never seen such a
delusional owner
and staff that are so desperate to do
their jobs
and now i've got to sleep in this
christ almighty
oh [ __ ]
what was that
this bed is so comfy
what is that noise on the stairs
i had a sleepless night and believe me
it wasn't a ghost that kept me awake it
was something far more frightening time
to give john and tina a wake-up call
after you please
hi guys
[Music]
these are the guests that have been
staying in the hotel um i've asked them
uh in my room this morning just to help
you understand how difficult it has
become for guests to actually stay here
who would like to go first i took a
shower this morning and used what i
thought was a clean towel and there was
hair in the towel and yeah that itself
was actually very uncomfortable
yeah we left our room last night and
couldn't lock our door so we had to
leave our hotel room door unlocked
hand on hearts how many of you would
return here no no
no no no no no no
anyone
not unless you're paying me to stay here
john and tina are you aware of so many
problems inside these rooms
some of them we are working on what i'm
more
pissed off about than anything is that
last night i went downstairs
in fact let me show you it's easier if i
do it this way i forgot my toothbrush i
went down to the car
and i cannot believe this just watch
carefully
i went outside
so step down the stairs
and all of a sudden damn i've let myself
out i've got no keys to get back in
the bloody front door
is not locked at night
now
there's no night porter
there's no security
and then
shock horror
i went behind the reception desk
and every one of your keys
is hanging replicated in the pigeon box
wow
that's terrible
duplicate key for every room oh my god
credit card details personal cell
numbers it's all there
that's
why is the door not locked
there's no good reason to go yeah we
haven't locked it in a long time though
no about two years in this community you
have eight major burglaries within the
last 12 months
three registered sex offenders locally
in this community i mean how does that
make you feel that we were sleeping in
this hotel last night and each and every
one of us
was
vulnerable that's not okay so
irresponsible thank you thank you guys
thank you um can i can you stay here
with me and uh ladies and gentlemen
thank you
thank you thank you
john and tina have broken the first law
of hospitality keep your guests safe
john's so busy interfering with other
people's jobs he's lost sight of what
really matters
i'm not joking around on the burglaries
oh i'm the sex offender i know i know
your reputation could be over in seconds
and one incident in this hotel
because you're not going to walk round
this town
as a prosecutor a chief lawyer
and then be responsible for a serious
rape taken in place inside here
wake up
you're running a business
not a courtroom
and they're here for an experience not a
[ __ ] sentence
sell the place
because you're not fit to run it sell it
because this is madness
sell it
and keep your house
[Music]
i've just discovered that john has lost
sight of the big picture at the hotel
the bloody front door
is not locked at night and his
incompetence is putting the guest safety
in jeopardy
if john doesn't change his interfering
ways he and tina will lose their home
and be forced to live in the hotel's top
floor
it's time to find out what it's like up
there
[Music]
hello
anyone there
hello
it's like summer oh [ __ ]
bloody hell
who in the hell
we put this here
this really is hotel hell
oh my god
welcome to our hands
this place is genuinely disturbing
freaky
that top floors no place to live but
i've got a plan if i force john to see
how different things could be here maybe
he'll get the message so i'm going to
need britney's help
if we can prove
to john and tina if you take charge and
you hold those reins that you
can make money for this hotel
trust me they back off and you step up
okay yeah absolutely i hear it i'm
hoping to prove to john that it can be
busy it can be fun here tonight we are
serving
we are doing a bar night oh my god this
is terrible we're not a
rowdy kid doing shots going crazy bar
it's a party party party we're gonna do
drink specials we can get people in the
rooms a ladies night tonight i have to
pack the place thanks bye
this is the first step to change as last
minute preparations take place in the
bar on the kitchen there's a new energy
in the hotel
this is chef richie's chance to prove he
can cook with fresh ingredients nothing
out of a bag please no preheated all
fresh yeah alfred great
rich
it's your responsibility to teach these
guys how to cook absolutely not to
re-heat is that right scoot yeah yeah
absolutely you just started culinary
school oh good man i didn't inspire you
to be a chef i had relatives everywhere
pushing me to join the culinary field
because
i wasn't physically able to do any other
things like sports and stuff yeah what's
the disability i've had
two heart surgeries and two back
surgeries how old are you 19. now you
move fast that's a big asset you haven't
been taught properly yet have you
that's incredible
so what do you want to be when you grow
up um i would like to have my own bakery
and be a professional executive pastry
chef wow we're ready to roll
brittany has gotten the word out that
she's in charge tonight and people are
flocking into the hotel there you go
okay let me ring them up
ladies night is going really well
tonight there's a mixed crowd of ages
here
and everyone hanging out together and
having fun
what can i do to help you nothing get
out
tonight's going great but i don't think
john quite understands how important
nights like this are because
i don't think this guy gets the message
john
i want to show you something come with
me
[Music]
that thing spooks me every time i come
in here
here's the situation
downstairs currently there's a buzz
and i got put together by your general
manager brittany
that's her vision
but
if you
carry on running
the cambridge the way you have been this
is what you're gonna have this is what's
your destiny this
on your own so stay up here
and sort of enjoy your surroundings
i'll come and get you when i'm ready all
right
he's so wrong he has no clue and i'm i'm
thinking when he comes back up he's
going to ask me what did i learn and i'm
going to say to him i really didn't
learn anything
i've locked john the hotel's interfering
owner on the top floor i need to
demonstrate to him how well the hotel
can run without him
i'm not happy sitting there waiting
because i know my guests are downstairs
having a party
and i kind of felt that i needed to be
downstairs
gordon's wants me to sit up here and and
you know think that he's all right about
all this stuff and
damn it he's wrong talking about me
being a control freak
with ladies night in full swing chef's
fiancee
and john and tina's daughter shea
arrives to join in the fun
[Applause]
[Music]
i think she's my last chance of getting
through to john hi shane hey how are you
got one minute 30 seconds excuse me
thank you
time's running out for your dad for your
mother
and for their house i can't get through
to your father i asked him to go
upstairs and just sit and ponder and
think that this is your future
and if you think he's ready to change by
all means bring him down and if he's not
i don't care
keep him out of there and keep him up
there
hey pops
what's going on i'm just up here uh
sitting down and waiting
waiting to go back downstairs
i think the point um
was to try and visualize what
could potentially be
the future oh no i've been doing a lot
of thinking okay i've been doing a lot
of thinking
i thought my role was about the same all
along
i feel like it's changed a lot and i
think a lot of it is
a fear of trusting
you don't have to be here all the time
when was the last time you sat down at
home and had a dinner with mom you know
yeah i feel guilty when i'm not here
do you know what's going on downstairs
no
it's awesome there is a
restaurant full of
people that are
thoroughly enjoying themselves
it's happened
and it's working without you
yeah
yeah
i'm i'm getting it okay i mean i'm um
it's going to be tough for me to back
walk of the working i think it's
important for you i think it's important
for you and mom
you know you're making a good point shay
i think you would be able to spend more
time with your granddaughter i'd love
that
it's possible
you don't want this to be your future no
you don't want to live here no i don't
you have to commit to change yeah yeah
i i understand
if mom will put up with me being home
more
love you i love you too shay
i i've it's an epiphany i've i've just
now realized
my control is what dre is dragging the
hotel down now i need to make a change
um in order for my personal life to
improve
and for my business to get better
good job
tonight has been a real success seeing
brittany in charge and rich cooking
fresh food gives me real hope but is
john capable of letting go my goodness
it feels weird it's sounding so quiet
now right ah well done behind the bar
well done in the kitchen
scooter well done ladies great i mean
you couldn't get a a seat at the bar
within 20 minutes that's how it should
be how much do we take it's under
fourteen hundred dollars in two hours
fourteen hundred dollars
in two hours
we made more than
the last four wednesdays or four
thursdays combined
john you spent the majority of night
upstairs how was your night it was in a
very good night actually
in what way um my daughter shay um
opened my eyes to some things i'm here
every night because i feel that i need
to be here
that that is my role as the owner
to wave the flag as a military term but
when i when it came from shea
as she said you know dad
i know how hard you work and and i
promised i wasn't going to tear up
and
this all happened without me you trust
your subordinates as a commander the
most important person you have are your
ncos
and chef and brittany are my ncos
i can't tell you how good is to hear
that
because you were a [ __ ] tough nut to
crack
because we have got one hell of a day
tomorrow
but i need everybody everybody at their
best
good job welcome good great job
what are they
i'm hoping that john has finally got
that message but is it all lawyer crap
tomorrow we'll definitely find out
freezing
[Music]
my design team worked all night to bring
the hotel into the 21st century now it's
time to reveal the new cambridge hotel
to the staff
good morning good morning john how you
feeling i can't wait to see what you've
done in there right you're ready to go
in yes the only way we're getting in is
with this a key let's go
let's go the door is locked
so your guests can sleep safe and sound
come in unlocks good good
right come upstairs
i'm hoping you're gonna love my room
i think it's absolutely gorgeous
[Music]
oh my god look at the floor wow
taking the carpet out and putting that
flooring in absolutely transformed it
the wallpaper was expensive in order to
enhance it we work with it
so we've got the back drapes above the
bed we have this amazing new floor
perfect furniture that fits the room
we've upgraded every
room with brand new linen and towels 75
000 worth of linen oh my god oh my god
we could have never afforded that that
is so wonderful i feel like kind of like
a kid that comes down christmas morning
and there's so many things under the
tree that
you're in overload i can't really
comprehend everything yet i mean i'm
just kind of looking at saying wow
ready for one more room oh my god i
don't know if i could take it
wow
wow wow
wow
i can't wait to actually show a guest
upstairs to a room i like i love it i
love it i love it um there's one more
little thing i want to show you
downstairs come with me please
in the 1890s the cambridge hotel gave
birth to world famous piler mode and i
think that dish can put the hotel back
on the map today something i thought was
a huge missed opportunity i've been
working on an amazing very special
apple pie recipe that i'm going to give
to you that you own and it becomes the
best apple pie in america and on the
back of that
we've transformed this
room through here
to the ala mode room come through
morning everybody how are we
we can
sell our own pie that's homemade that
gordon is giving us
his recipe for oh my god
this hotel invented pile of mode
and the ice cream is made fresh here
with a brand new ice cream maker and
it's
locally sauce cream i can't wait to try
it
come with me please enjoy the apple pie
nice to see you
please come through beautiful pile of
mode
dig in dig in come on guys
if anybody wants this you better get on
it
oh my god that's awesome the world
famous cambridge hotel apple pie a la
mode
that is the best crust i have ever had
on a pie
welcome to the cambridge hotel we now
have the best apple pile of mode in i'd
say the world people are gonna be
excited
scary what do you think bud
i'm shocked you're shocked are you happy
i don't know what to say oh mate don't
get upset buddy
what's the matter i'm so happy oh good
i'm happy too as well you know that okay
seeing how much he changed the hotel was
very overwhelming
oh i can feel a chance i'm a lot more
inspired right now i feel like i could
accomplish anything in the kitchen
i am proud now there's a new pride in me
to say
this is where i work
time to go i never thought i'd say this
but i'm actually quite sad to leave this
place because no longer is john in
denial he can now stand back and watch
his team run the cambridge properly
as i'm getting ready to leave guests are
starting to arrive at the new hotel
hello welcome guys how are you
and the biggest change of all is not the
new decor it's the fact that guests are
loving it at the cambridge
this is beautiful
the restaurant is buzzing the cambridge
burger with the pork belly guests are
enjoying the new home cooked menu that i
put together with chef rich
and you better save room for the pie
because it's totally different i'm just
trying the apple pie and the hotel's
signature dish piler mode is a big hit
that ice cream is worth driving for
fantastic
great buzz in there i mean it's electric
and
it's the sound of the new cambridge
hotel my only hope now is that they keep
it up and
keep those customers excited because
when it's like that is phenomenal
is that good
i think tonight went incredibly well the
fact that i could stay and sit with shay
and addison and funk
it was really really nice
wow
to see you smiling is incredible you
know that yeah you like this place up
but i don't want you living here no i'm
not i don't want to live here i do not
want you living here i won't live here
okay
tell him that i'm not living here i hear
you i'll give him a hug he deserves one
he has an interfere tonight and you sat
down and spent time with your
granddaughter i had a blast yeah
my job is done let me tell you
no longer
r.i.p
okay of the cambridge it has a bright
future it's long live the cambridge
right that's absolutely right before
gordon came i didn't know where to go
anymore with the hotel and getting
gordon here
and having him show us
what the problem was now i can see that
the things can be fixed
i'll tell you okay colin powell says
optimism is a force multiplier
i'm optimistic
stay optimistic but don't get too
involved okay okay
look after yourselves thank you very
much stay together thank you thank you
thank you
before i leave this place there's one
more person i want to talk to want a big
man
so you've got three more years left at
college right
about four okay hear me out okay i want
you to keep in touch with me okay i'll
give my email address because i want to
finance those next four years in college
personally
and help you okay do it for you and keep
that dream alive one day of owning your
bakery and then when your bakery's open
all i want back is a loaf of bread
okay
it's pretty unbelievable that he is
going to be able to finance my four
years of school
well done
good job thank you so much welcome
can't wait to finish school we came off
for that big loaf of bread
you have an amazing pair of hands and a
lovely smile
don't stop okay
and god help you if you fail that
college thank you you won't though i
know you won't well done thank you okay
when i go to school i'm gonna push
myself two hundred times harder i'm
gonna show gorin what i can do and how
fast i can do it good night thank you
well thank you very much thank you thank
you thank you well done thank you
oh good job man awesome hey you deserve
it
definitely
what a week
what a place
and now whenever i see elemode i know
where it started
you